I just got a tumblr I do not understand
tumblr don't really know what a note is
don't really like the feeling of being
followed by strangers why do they call
them followers can't we just be friends
I have 81 followers mostly strangers and
they send me messages that say thanks
for the reblog but what of all that
feminism on your feet I did not was long
we were still putting with her long hair
did you really need a queer haircut I
did not respond
my grandmother's been taking care of me
since I was a kid found out I'm gay but
she keeps telling me I'm just going
through a phase
it's really getting to me what should I
do yes I like your poetry phase now a
distinct period in the process of change
or development I'm seven years old and
leaving a play date from Samantha's
house I give her a kiss on the cheek and
both of our mothers swoon I'm seven
years old and leaving a play date from
Michael's house I give him a kiss on the
cheek and his mother says now that's
enough of face verb to introduce in
gradual stages I was 22 years old when I
began dating a woman for the first time
she pulled me in from the starless
darkness I'd been drifting through and I
watched as all my insecurities burned up
in her atmosphere her name is face verb
to remove in gradual stages in high
school I knew this painter a cocksure
comment with a confident smarter than
you smile that showed no signs of burnin
out a hopeful romantic who always wanted
to exchange portraits for poems and I'm
afraid if I write him one now it will
sound too much like the suicide note
that he did not leave signed phase verb
the process of waxing and waning it
takes the moon 29 days orbit around the
Earth appearing to us only in fractions
of itself is Ferb to illuminate the
darkness and what are we really ever
doing if not constantly trying to find
the light when they tell you your love
is just a phase tell them you do not
like the word just you are not just
anything do not bury your demons on the
Dark Side of the Moon instead raise hey
out of your sky when they treat your
love like an eclipse like it means
learning to live in
one else's shadow like it deserves to be
blackhole swallowed because it burns too
bright to look at do not let them do not
align yourself with someone else's axis
of expectation do not fight your own
Pole trust in your own gravity we are
closest and stars and they will ever be
and if anyone ever tries to tell you
that you love wrong
if anyone waits for you to backwards
become yourself treats your clearness
has anything other than infinite
universe of beautiful possibilities that
it is tell them that you're sorry that
they'd rather live in darkness then
learn to love your light learn to love
your flicker flash irradiation learn to
love you full moon and even on the days
when you hang just a sliver in the sky
when it feels like you're holding on for
dear life to this rock like you are in a
death grip tango with the Sun hold on
because I've seen people I love starve
themselves out of the sky her name is
Sarah
signed Andrew my starry-eyed girl and
her constellation kisses my man in the
moon in his ghostly glow I still don't
understand tumblr but I consider us
friends thank you for sending us your
secret satellite we promised it did not
get lost in space PS we hear you loud
and clear